I HAVE TO ASK A QUESTION HERE,
IS NOT SNITCHING STILL A
THING IN THE BLACK
COMMUNITY.
I THOUGHT WE GOT OVER THAT
LIKE JHERI CURLS AND BLACK
BART SIMPSON T-SHIRTS, FOR
ANY SNITCHING NOVICES, STOP
SNITCHING WAS A MOVEMENT
TO TRY AND CONVINCE THE
BLACK PEOPLE TO NOT TALK
TO THE POLICE WHICH RAISES
THE QUESTION, SOMEBODY
REALLY NEEDED TO ORGANIZE
THAT?
NOW AS MISGUIDED AS THE STOP
SNITCHING CAMPAIGN IS IT WAS
DEFINITELY A THING THAT
CAUGHT ON IN THE EARLY AUGHTS
AND THE GUY WHO
ORGANIZED IT WAS THIS GUY,
SKINNY SUGE, NOT TO BE
CONFUSED WITH FULL SIZED
SUGE.
WHO AS I SAID BEFORE WAS
ACCUSED OF RUNNING OVER CLE
BONE SLOAN, ALLEGEDLY.
EVEN THOUGH IT'S ON CAMERA
AND EVERYBODY SAW IT.
CLE BONE, I JUST SNITCHED
FOR YOU, MAN, I DID
THAT FOR YOU.
DID IT.
(APPLAUSE)
>> HELPING A BROTHER OUT,
HELPING A BROTHER OUT.
ANYWAY, SKINNY SUGE-- WAS
THE GUY FROM BALTIMORE WHO
MADE A SERIES OF STOP
SNITCHING DVDs IN WHICH HE
SAID THINGS LIKE THIS.
>> SNITCHES, BITCH I HATE
ALL YOU-- [BLEEP].
>> Larry: NOT ON PAR WITH
THE I HAVE A DREAM SPEECH,
BUT IN HIS DEFENSE, ACTUALLY
THERE IS NO DEFENSE.
NOW SINCE THEN SKINNY SUGE
AND EVEN THE GUY WHO SHOT
THAT VIDEO WOUND UP IN JAIL.
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY WERE
SNITCHED ON OR NOT BUT I GET
WHY THAT WOULD BE THEIR
CAUSE.
NOW OF COURSE, NOW SNITCHING
ISN'T JUST LIMITED TO BLACK
CULTURE, EVERYBODY HAS A
SNITCH CODE, JUST ASK ROBERT
DE NIRO.
>> NEVER RAT ON YOUR FRIENDS,
AND ALWAYS KEEP YOUR MOUTH
SHUT.
>> Larry: YEAH, SEE, THIS
CODE OF SILENCE WORKS FOR
BOTH GANGSTER AND GANGSTA.